the County Sheriff in Panama City
Florida says he's worried that more
people haven't evacuated yet that city
hasn't had a direct hit from a hurricane
since 1895 CBS Evening News anchor Jeff
Glor is in Panama City leading our
coverage of hurricane Michael from
Florida
Jeff good morning it is stunning to hear
how historic and how big it is chilling
how bad this hurricane has gotten how
quickly it has gotten there the water is
coming up here winds picking up heavy
rain now for a couple hours at least
about 375,000 people have cleared out
the Florida Panhandle as hurricane
Michael seems to get worse by the minute
it took less than 36 hours for Michael
to strengthen from a tropical storm to a
major hurricane Michael is now racing
toward Florida's panhandle were hundreds
of thousands of people have gotten out
of the way homes and business owners
filled sandbags and boarded up windows
leaving streets and marinas deserted at
the supermarket shelves are empty if
you're on the fence about thinking about
whether to evacuate don't be on the
fence this storm can kill you
emergency officials have sent at least a
hundred troopers with the Florida
Highway Patrol to the Panhandle also
here to help search and rescue teams
from States as far away as Pennsylvania
and Indiana its humanity is going out
and helping folks that who are in need
at Tyndall Air Force Base near Panama
City officials evacuated crews and
fighter jets but not everyone in the
storms projected path is leaving never
been through a hurricane before heard
lots about it watch them on television
would stay and see it out my daughter's
want me to go and I'm like no stay it'll
be fine love fun
hurricane michael has already left its
mark on parts of Central America killing
at least 13 people across our Salvador
Honduras and Nicaragua in Cuba the storm
dumped nearly a foot of rain destroying
homes and knocking out power a Royal
Caribbean cruise ship bound for Havana
got caught in the hurricane forcing
passengers on board to ride out the
winds and rain